comment quelques mots tapés sur un
moteur de recherche peuvent en dire long
sur l'année que nous avons passé sport
eco vide 19 voilà comment résumer 2021
en france si l'on en croit le palmarès
des mots les plus recherchés sur google
euros 2021 ligue 1 où roland garros se
partagent le top 10 des recherches avec
confinement passe sanitaires ou encore
attestation couvre-feu les millennials
américain entre 25 à 35 ans écrivent
leur testament certains passent par des
sites internet ils le font rapidement ça
dure environ une heure ça coûte minimum
100 dollars d'autres font directement
appel à des cabinets d'avocats
[Musique]
avic et stan comme un avocat new yorkais
raconte qu'au moment de l'arrivée du
variant delta aux états unis il a reçu
une multitude de coups de fil de
millennial ce qu'ils voulaient à tout
prix rédiger leur testament et c'est
bien le covin 19 qui a entraîné cette
peur en tout cas ce phénomène
on a même compris des dicos daniel dans
la baignoire
vous avez compris ce qu'il faut faire
rester chez soi c'est tout
jekel feutrée rester chez soi et là vous
êtes je suis dehors donc
vous faites pas bien l'exercice jolfa
moitié crise sanitaire oblige nous nous
sommes très souvent demandé quand parle
emmanuel macron ou qui peut se faire
vacciner ce cher google a réponse à tout
et même aux questions les plus
surprenantes et pourtant souvent posée
comme par exemple pourquoi les
tronçonneuses ont elles été inventé un
grand grand grand grand grand merci à
maison saint gobain chez moi si vous
voulez qu'on n'a pas le droit
malheureusement les faits datant de la
fin que jean castex calabrais dans cette
bombe myriade on va renverser meriane il
va falloir remercier très fort quand
même nos amis ces maisons saint gobain
qui s'est occupée voilà c'est juste
fabuleux l'amiable
je suis désolé je demande que vous
interromps pied monsieur le maire
m'interrompt tout temps mais on voulait
aussi de l'interpellation
pour m'interrompt sont demandés les ce2
et moi restons l'un des l'adversaire je
vous respecte non vous ne respectez pas
vos m'interrompez t je ne connaissais
pas vous ne verrez c'est parce que ma
démonstration allez-y donc choisir
exhorta monde je dis bien je ne dirai
besoin du soutien des as salam et pour
m'interrompt excusez moi c'est leur
travail
vous n'êtes que dans l'injonction vous
n'êtes que dans la morale vous n'êtes
que dans le prêche vous n'êtes c'est
fascinant les gens de gauche aujourd'hui
c'est à dire nous manger ceci ne roulait
pas en voiture et ce que je peux
terminer bien sûr je vois je souhaite
vous est absolument insupportable ou
maintenant dès qu'on peut laisser
termine une phrase et puis après vous
répondre
[Applaudissements]
un
[Musique]
débat très important organisé entre la
ministre de la citoyenneté et la papesse
de la télé réalité qui était accompagné
par cinq candidates parmi elles victoria
maïssane isabeau l'ena né vers lille dès
leur arrivée au ministère on a senti que
les prix n'étaient pas très rodé sur les
formalités et l'attitude à adopter de
manière juste chine ans alors par contre
on respecte le président de la
république y voilà merci semaine on
n'est quand même pas une cour d'école 1
il faut quand même passer pour des gens
réfléchis et kiki ceux qui disent quand
même non qu'as tu te trompes complet on
n'est pas ici pourquoi c'est pour
développer dans la france entière pas
bon on est ici pour montrer de la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui quelques clubs
qui montent comme hanks est d'aider les
jeunes aujourd'hui crois que c'est ça
ouais on tu crois qu'on est ici pour
redire way lors les grossièretés on
entend toutes les cinq minutes bref vous
l'avez compris sur les réseaux sociaux
plus de vidéos qui ressemble à un goûter
entre copines que du débat à proprement
parler quelqu'un rigole shebab ne vient
pas on veut dès que
vous soyez pas considérer mes concerts
mais consterné
je sais je sais pas lesquels émotions
fait l'âne pour avoir du son comme
disait mon père et ça vous va très bien
deuxièmement sur le bataclan savez
monsieur je n'ai jamais dit
pardonnez-moi sur lui mais son envoi de
président de la république
on respecte les hommes et des femmes qui
vous parle mais moi je vous respecte je
ne vous interromps pas c'est vous qui ne
le respectent et en avez-vous moins de
maternité nous avons dit je joue banane
assez vite de par ma timidité à ma
sensibilité les cheveux longs m'ont aidé
au siam à me protéger à mon frère a
personnellement tout le monde les
commandes tout le monde a un avis en
parlait d'ailleurs dit tout le monde
voyait tout le monde a quelque chose à
dire sur les cheveux ou le climat mais
en même temps et la suite de la phrase
c'est bien que les deux amis vers le
pire personne ne se battra pas
globalement ça caille sauf que nous le
matin pour le savoir un soin on regarde
la pluie météo soit on le fait à
l'ancienne en ouvrant la fenêtre mais
les influenceurs eux ils ont un autre
indicateur pour comprendre que dehors il
fait froid mais si à munich a infligé ce
matin c'est tout
voilà moi je pense qu'on se contente
parce que comme elle dit complète
contente c'est à dire que ce gars comme
ça tu es content voilà donc où
bref une dent en fait on se contente
vous savez que été bâton mais j'ai dit
ça
certains ne plaisant pas du tout avec
l'esprit de noël en allemagne un couple
à installer pas moins de 444 sapin en
plastique dans sa maison un record du
monde au total sur douze mille boulet 47
mille lumières de plusieurs centaines de
guirlandes ornent ses sapins et tout est
rentré dans leur maison de 110 m²
bravo mon gérant des mets quinté d'isis
hadji moussa même le père noël il ferme
le rouge à
l'est
mais t'es ouf monique je suis tellement
désolée ne pas avoir pu vous offrir ces
toilettes japonaises que je vais quand
même essayer de me rattraper avec ce
cadeau monique ça me fait tellement
plaisir
faute d'avoir offert les toilettes à
5000 euros vraiment prenez en soin
c'était pas là ne nous regardez pas
comme ça tout est normal c'est la
télévision des films intéresse et rapide